- [Voiceover] Let's say that
we have a function, f of x,
and it is equal to negative
four times the cube root
times the cube root of x.
And what we want to do
is we want to evaluate
the derivative of our function
when x is equal to eight.
So see if you can figure this out.
All right, now this might
look foreign to you.
You might say, well, I've
never taken a derivative
of a cube root before, but as we'll see,
we can actually just
apply the power rule here.
Because this function can be rewritten as,
so f of x can be rewritten
as negative four.
The cube root of x is the same thing as
x to the one-third power.
And now it might be a little bit clearer
that we can apply the power rule.
We could take this one-third, multiply it
by this co-efficient, negative four.
So we have negative four times one-third,
and you have times x to the one-third.
We just decrement that exponent to,
that's a different shade of blue,
to the one-third minus one power.
This is the derivative.
So f prime of x is equal to that,
and so now we just have to simplify.
This is equal negative
four-thirds times x.
One-third minus one is
negative two-thirds power.
And so if we want to
evaluate f prime of eight,
f prime of eight is equal
to negative four-thirds
times eight to the
negative two-thirds power.
Well that's the same thing
as negative four-thirds
times eight, eight to the one-third,
and then raise that to negative two power.
I'm just using exponent properties here.
If this looks completely
unfamiliar how I got
from that to that, I encourage you
to review exponent
properties on Khan Academy.
Well eight to the
one-third, that is just two.
So this is just two, and then
two to the negative two power.
Remember, let me just
take some steps here.
It's a good review.
This is equal to negative four-thirds
times two to the negative
two is the same thing
as one over two to the two.
These two things are equivalent.
That and that.
One over two to the two is the same thing
as two to the negative two.
So this is one over four,
and so this is going to simplify to
negative one over three.
Is equal to negative one over three,
and we are done.